[Music]
um
do
[Music]
hello good evening
hi
welcome to the table
welcome to july at the table my name is
karen
and i am really glad that you're here
tonight thank you for making time and
braving the heat and
everything else sometimes you know 99 of
the battle is just getting here and
you're here you made it
and i hope the service is a blessing for
you and meets you right where you are
tonight
um
speaking of july at the table july is
our month here to downshift and take
some time to intentionally rest and so
much of our culture is about going and
doing
achieving
and it's very counter-cultural just to
stop
and be
and remember that god is god and we are
not
and so that's what july is all about so
brett takes a few weeks off we get the
joy of having some great guest speakers
here tonight's one of those nights in
the next few weeks we're going to have
some wonderful guest speakers that you
won't want to miss
and
i would encourage all of you to find
space and margin this month to just be
to just be
take some time to just calm yourself
listen to your breaths
um
yeah just allow for some space
to do that and uh you will usually find
god there in some way whether it's
through nature uh through
just being quiet um
so i hope you'll take some time to do
that this month
i have one announcement
for august and it's for our kiddos we're
going to have our summerama kids camp
that's happening august 5th and 6th it's
going to be super fun it's going to be
right here at pleasant valley and it's
free
it's for kids entering kindergarten
through finished sixth grade this past
school year so not just for our table
kids here but be thinking about who you
know that might
want to come and enjoy that we want this
to be a gift for families and so help us
to make it a gift for families here and
outside of our table community
brittany and her team have some great
things planned
and
if you're an adult and actually if
you're an older teenager i believe you
can volunteer to help
and be a part of it it's super fun and
so britney has a sign up sheet in the
back it's at that little table right
before you exit this room
if you could put your name down i think
name email let brittany know that you're
interested in volunteering and she will
find a spot for you it will be so so fun
so we hope you will join for that if you
would like to register your kiddos then
you can do that
on our facebook page and also on our
live stream tonight if you're watching
online james will have that link
available for you to click on just put
in the information and you'll be good to
go sound good all right
um
i also have the honor of passing this
over to gary my husband
who
who wrote a poem
for this community and it's really
the the elder team founding members of
this community it's our heart for what
we want so we felt it was a great time
to share that so enjoy these words from
gary
we are the bold ones the ones who don't
fear to challenge the status quo
our thoughtfulness matters
our curiosity is beautiful
art beauty blood sweat and tears a
collage of friendship love
heartbreak and disappointment
it's okay
it's okay to be different let's agree
that it's okay to disagree
let's celebrate that we don't stand on
the same side of every issue
yet let us support encourage and lift
each other up
as brother and sister
come
sit eat listen talk laugh
cry
and be
sh
be still
breathe
hear the rhythm of your own heartbeat
tune into god's spirit
breathe him in
be filled up
and be poured out
be fragile be bold
be meek
be strong
seek the uncomfortable ways where god
leads and don't worry what others say
rise up praise him
and be not afraid
thank you gary
would you guys stand with us we're going
to go ahead and enter into some worship
together and if this is your first time
here this is an open space for anyone
so
please enter in if there are songs that
you know sing along if you don't know
them and would like to sit there and
take in the lyrics you are more than
welcome to do that
but i hope that you sense a little bit
of god's spirit as we sing this so
we're gonna go ahead and get started
[Music]
lord i find you in the seeking lord i
find you
in the town
and to know you is to love you and to
know
[Music]
oh
here we go
[Music]
of grace i need
ah
[Music]
is
i will find all i need all i need is
[Music]
bye
you are beautiful my sweet sweet song
[Music]
you are beautiful my sweet sweet songs
you are beautiful my sweet sweet song
i will sing again
you are so good to me
you heal my broken heart
you are
my father in heaven
you are so good to me
you heal my broken heart
you are my father in heaven
you are beautiful my sweet sweet song
you are beautiful my sweet
[Music]
you ride upon the clouds
you lead me to the truth
you are the spirit inside me
you are beautiful
you are beautiful my sweet sweet song
i will sing again
[Music]
you are
my dancing rhythm
[Music]
forever
you poured out all your blood
you died upon the cross
you are
my jesus who loves me sing that again
you poured out all your blood
you died upon the cross
you are
my jesus who loves me
you are beautiful my sweet sweet song
you are
[Music]
you beautiful
beautiful my sweet sweet song
i will sing again
[Music]
you are
my father in heaven
you are the spirit inside me
you are
my jesus who
loves me
[Music]
thank you for who you
thank you that are here with us
we're going to enter into the prayer of
our people and if um you haven't been
here before
there will be a prayer that we read
aloud together and then we'll leave some
space open for any of you to
speak out a name or situation that
you're carrying with you tonight maybe
something that's burdening you or
someone that's on your heart
and then we will close together with the
end of the prayer if you're online feel
free to leave your prayer requests in
the comments and we will read those
aloud
um thank you guys for entering into this
time with us
for the city of saxi texas and for every
city and community and all of those who
live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us
and the wisdom and the will to conserve
it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land see or air
for the old and the sick
for the widow and the orphan
for the injured and suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed
the unemployed and destitute for
prisoners and captives and for all who
remember and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us
and that you hear us
so we lift these names and situations up
to you
john
[Music]
dressy
for these names and moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we've
kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light
healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
and i've searched the world
but it couldn't fill me
a man's empty praise and treasures that
fade are never
[Music]
every desire is
[Applause]
[Music]
is
to show you my weakness
my failures and flaws lord you've seen
them all and you still call me friends
the god of the mountains
is the god of the valley
and there's not a place your mercy and
grace won't find me
[Music]
there's again
there's nothing that is
[Music]
is
let's see what god does
[Music]
you give beauty for ashes
you turn shame into glory
you're
[Music]
you turn bones into armies
you're the only one who cares
[Music]
better than you lord there's nothing
nothing is
[Music]
you turn morning to dancing
you give beauty for ashes
you turn shame into glory
you're the only one
who turn morning to dancing and
you give beauty for ashes
you turn shame into glory
you're the only
[Music]
you turn bones into armies
you turn seas into heights
[Music]
lord there's nothing
better than you or there's nothing
[Music]
better is you oh there's nothing
better than you or there's nothing
nothing is better than you
god we just believe
for all the things that we mentioned
earlier that we're carrying with us
tonight god
for the people who are struggling
in this room and outside
god we believe that you are the god
who takes our sickness
away
you are the god who brings light in our
darkness
you are the god who gives us hope
when nothing else is turning around
you're the one who stays steady with us
[Music]
you are our grounding center god and you
will hold
[Music]
because sometimes we're there on the
mountaintops and sometimes
we're down in the valley
and sometimes the prayers aren't
answered
and sometimes you feel very far away
but god we choose to believe that you
are here in us
working a good work
[Music]
god that you have the power
to turn our bones
into armies to turn our graves into
gardens
god would you show us how you're doing
that good work
[Music]
we want to trust you
god and we want to make room for you
[Music]
thank you that you're good that you're
with us that you love us
and that's enough
in jesus name
amen
guys you can sit down and turn as you do
to the people around you and welcome
them make them feel at home our kids are
very excited to be here
i'm just realizing i don't even think i
dismissed them earlier so i'm glad that
they found their way to their classroom
way to go kids you're getting the hang
of it
all right
karen's gonna take it from here
yes great thank you worship team that
was wonderful
ah
chris you're back
sorry
she saw saw a friend had to say hi um
as i mentioned it's july
so we send brett off just to enjoy he
works you guys he works so so hard for
this community
i'm sure you know and then whatever you
know add on about a hundred times more
and that's how much brett carries us in
his heart how much he he just works and
works to make this a community that's
living in its values and living towards
our mission and our vision and so it's
our joy to be able to send him off even
though we miss him um he gets some rest
and that's a good good thing that's a
god thing
um and
for tonight we have an extremely special
guest speaker who is already a big part
of the table like she this woman she
carries many plates at the table if i
can use that metaphor
and we couldn't let her go off into the
sunset with brett just yet like we would
really love if you spoke and gave the
message this week so maggie come on up
can you guys welcome maggie up here
[Applause]
this is one of my dear dear friends
somebody that
even though she is quite a bit younger
than me inspires me someone who i admire
for real for real
and to know maggie is to truly feel
known
and seen and loved if you've had any
sort of interaction with maggie i mean
she's just genuine to her core loves
jesus thanks ma thanks man and that just
flows through her and so i'm really
excited for her to share i have so much
more i could say about you but i really
we need to hear from you not me so
you're good with that mike i'll keep
this one and here's that okay thank you
for karen however you want it there you
go thank you thank you thank you
thank you worship team
i feel like the last song did a great
job preaching the sermon honestly so
i'm fine with that
um
i
i'm so i'm just thrilled anytime i get
to stand up here in front of you guys
but
i just want you to know
that whether you're here online or in
person your presence matters
so much to me and and it just is an
honor like i just feel beyond privilege
to stand here
so okay
i really love y'all i really do
um
and
i feel like maybe every message that i
ever preach i just
i always have some sort of warning at
the beginning but guys if of all the
messages that i've ever preached this
one has the biggest warning
mindy can attest
i have
been
mulling this one over and
we don't
here's the thing when i first found out
about the opportunity to speak in july i
was i was really excited because i
always look forward to the times that i
get to share with you guys and um
i
immediately i mean this is probably
something you shouldn't confess out loud
but i have no shame here so
i immediately started imagining like
that i was gonna just preach the most
powerhouse sermon you know what i mean
like i was
i look small and young
but
in my
i am a dragonfire
like in my spirit i'm just like we're
just gonna talk about all the things
that no one wants to talk about on
sundays you know and every systemic
issue in the world we're gonna tackle it
we're gonna nail it you know what i mean
we're just gonna deal with the giants
and i was ready and um
that's not the sermon that i'm preaching
tonight turns out
that um as i was sitting down to write
that powerhouse sermon um i was a little
humbled first of all by my lack of
qualifications to speak to any of the
things that i had originally if you
looked at the topics you know i'm just
like i mean all the things you know like
political policy and systemic racism and
i'm just like ready to go and i'm just
like i nope okay never mind um
but
um there's this verse in philippians
that also just kept coming to my mind
that was sort of a guiding light for me
as i wrote it so it felt wrong to not
start there tonight
and if you haven't spent a lot of times
in the book of philippians i do just
really encourage you to go and read it
because it is paul and timothy speaking
to believers about how to live out their
faith i mean it's just the most
practical hands-on encouraging edifying
thing like it's so helpful so um but
the verse that was standing out to me
actually
is about halfway through the book
and it's in the middle of this long
monologue that's just riveting and
beautiful and inspiring that paul and
timothy are giving on how believers
should work out their salvation and it's
a beautiful thing but all of a sudden in
verse 15 16 it's like paul just pauses
which is funny because he's writing a
letter but it's as if he knows like
about this time people are going to be
getting really uncomfortable and i think
i should just pause and give a little
aside and this is what philippians 3 15
and 16 says
all of us who are mature should take
such a view of things speaking of
everything that he had just laid out
but if on some point you think
differently that too god will make clear
to you only let us live up to what we
have already attained
and it's that last sentence that just
kept ringing in my head as i was sitting
down trying to figure out like what is
it of all the things that
it's you know inside of me what is it
that i should speak to on this night and
i couldn't help but think of those words
just live up to what you've already
attained maggie because i'll be honest
all the big dragons that i wanted to
slay i have not attained any of those
things i am like elementary school you
know preschool level and um
what i want to do tonight is i just want
to do my best to stay in my lane of what
i know to be true in my lived experience
and present that to you so
this is going to be the non-not
[Music]
non-trendy or you know hot topic sermon
it's instead it's more like a tale as
old as time
and um i've titled it the reason i'm
still here so
um
uh several years back um brett and i
bought a house
on a property with my twin sister mindy
and her husband josh and towards the
beginning of um living together we
played this game of sorts sort of like
in an effort to get to know each other
better and like help each other go below
the surface of typical conversation and
this game you like go through this list
of questions which are
strange and most of them extremely
awkward and you pick a question and you
pick any individual in the group to ask
it to and they have to answer the
question
now most of the questions that i
remember from that night would not be
appropriate to repeat in this particular
setting but as we got further into the
game um we decided to go off script a
little bit and we started asking each
other just some of our own honest brave
vulnerable questions and just directed
it and said like hey okay this is i'm
picking you i want to ask you this
question
and um
i'll never forget my brother-in-law josh
was at the tail end of like a
decade-long oh gosh
journey of
so silly
it's it's going to pass um
he was at the end of this decade-long
journey of deconstruction in his faith
and his relationship with god and trying
to make sense of all of it
and
i think i get emotional because it was
it was such a vulnerable moment but i
remember
him looking at me and saying okay my
question is for maggie and i was like
ready i mean yeah we had been talking
about ridiculous things ridiculous
and all of a sudden he pulls this out he
goes maggie
after growing up as a christian your
whole life and being raised in the
church
and seeing all the good and the bad and
the whole mixture of the whole thing and
knowing everything that you know now
why are you still there
like what makes you stick around
and
i
have to say like there's this verse in
first peter that says always be prepared
to give an answer for the hope that is
in you
and in that moment
i was not prepared like i was extremely
caught off guard
and
partly because i knew josh really well
and i knew the deep journey that he had
been on and how hard it had been and i
wanted so badly to give this really
eloquent response you know of like
laying out my stance for salvation that
would just be riveting and solve all the
questions you know
um
but i sat there for a minute and i
thought about it
and the most honest answer that i could
muster is the topic that i want us to
talk about tonight and it is this
the story of jesus
is the one that has taught me to die to
myself so that i can live beyond myself
and even if i walked away from it all
that would still be the truth that is
saving my life and um
i
i go back to that moment so often
um
because
it's interesting to me that the story of
jesus is the story of love incarnate
right lived out in front of us but in
particular it's the story of love
through death and resurrection
and i think that we love talking about
love and we love talking about
resurrection
we don't love talking about death
we'd rather skip that middle section if
possible
and um
i feel like
that
unfortunately
is even true in our churches and the
reason i say that is because
we do not have a shortage of churches
like i feel like right now you could go
in a five mile radius and probably see
even
two or three new buildings being built
as churches like in the south where we
live in the bible belt there's so many
christians who say that they ascribe to
faith in jesus
but there's so few people who know how
to die
so few people who know how to lay down
our lives
and unfortunately
i i think that's on us i think sometimes
the gospel we're preaching is skipping
over the death and resurrection portion
and um
i i remember the first time that this
stood out to me was actually when i was
a teenager
we grew up in the area we had this
white big old van with navy blue stripes
around and it had like cool curtains
inside
it was really classy
but mom was driving us down central
expressway
yes central expressway highway 75 is
that the name okay
that's why she was driving on me but we
are driving down central expressway and
it was coming up on um this big event
that was going to be held in our county
really um for see you at the poll that
was coming up soon and i remember
driving past this massive billboard on
the side that was new and i had never
seen it before but it was
um advertising this big like communal
community-wide event where all the youth
groups from all these different cities
we're going to gather together for see
you at the pole and you know what i mean
kind of like
renew their faith in christ type thing
and the billboard i remember was just
pure white background and it had these
huge
bold face lettering on it and this is
what it said
stand up for jesus
and then the time and the place written
at the bottom
and it occurred to me in that moment
what a contradiction of messaging
that that billboard was
from the actual call of jesus
and i thought to myself
how odd
that a religion
formed around someone who came to lay
down his life sacrificially and die on a
cross
is now like his pinnacle moment of mr of
ministry you know was crucifixion
and
this same leader that we're following
now we're encouraging our young people
that the best way to follow him
is to stand up for jesus
take a stand and as if he like needs us
to defend him in some way
and
i it hit me then like
wait a minute
isn't that the exact opposite of what
jesus said
i
i'm gonna read it because
in matthew 16 24 i'm afraid i'll
misquote it for you but
i mean just to like give us an example
and i feel like there's a ton of
scriptures that we could pick from but
specifically matthew 16 24 he jesus says
to his disciples
if anyone would come after me
he must deny himself
and take up his cross
and follow me
whoever wants to save his life will lose
it but whoever loses his life for me
will find it
if anyone wants to come after me he must
deny himself and take up his cross and
follow me and i thought wow we're taking
this call of like sacrifice and
surrender and twisting it into something
that's like stand up and defend
that's a totally different posturing
that's a that's a totally different call
and unfortunately
a lot of times our churches are right at
the front of that charge
and
that concerns me
but at the same time it doesn't surprise
me because this is the way of all of us
this is the way of humanity
this is how we work as human beings
basic survival skills right
and honestly even if you look at the
story of jesus in the bible
when he's in the garden
and um the mob comes to arrest him and
take him to trial his own disciple peter
like he had his own
stand up for jesus moment right
like the mob's coming
they're gonna arrest jesus and what does
peter do
he pulls out a sword
slashes the guy's ear off one of the
guards ears off
and
you know is ready to take a stand for
jesus
he's ready to defend
because that's what we do
we don't like the dying part of
salvation we just like the living
the staying alive part
and peter was doing what any of us would
do right that's that's just human nature
but what does jesus do
he goes over
picks up the guy's ear
puts it back on the side of his head
looks at peter and rebukes him peter
this is not the way that love's gonna
overcome evil
this is not the way the will of god is
gonna come through
through violence
jesus
is always teaching this counter-cultural
way of
denial of self and what does he do in
that moment he just surrenders
he just lets them drag him off and goes
to his trial
because
here's the secret
jesus is not concerned with staying
alive he's
concerned with
being fully alive
that's
a totally different posturing he's not
trying to save his life
his own life
and he's teaching us to do the same he's
setting that model for us that if you
really want to live if you really want
to experience life of the ages
it's more than just staying alive and i
think that's why if you read
john 10 10
he says
what is it the thief comes to steal
kill and destroy but i have come that
they may have life
and
have it to the full life abundantly
he's saying i want you to do more than
just stay alive this is more than just
blood and oxygen
this is about life to the full
and the dichotomy of it all is that if
you look at the life of jesus
that involves a certain death that
involves a certain dying and when i say
death or dying i'm not talking about
physical death here although i think
jesus life has implications for our
physical death but
i think what he's talking about in those
scriptures is not just what happens to
us after we die physically he's talking
about dying to ourselves to our
tendencies for self-protection and
self-promotion and self-defense and in
the end it becomes kind of
self-obsession
right
because here's the thing
no matter
what kind of upbringing you had or how
healthy or unhealthy your family of
origin was whether you grew up rich or
poor christian non-christian other
the common denominator between all of us
are these tendencies for self-protection
and and you know name self-defense and
survival right these are these are
things that were really helpful for us
when we were young we needed them as
babies right
this is how they survive when
something's wrong if they're hurting or
if they're hungry they're gonna yell out
they're gonna cry and let you know about
it you know and when kids are on the
playground and they're like developing
social skills and trying to figure out
how to make their way in the world you
know there's a lot of that happening
those those survival instincts that are
kicking in you know what i mean like
i've got
boys right now who
i mean we are in the thick of survival
instincts i mean
jesse knows
oh survival of the fittest and i don't
know who's going to win right now i
don't know
but um
these are the things that we all
you know need to do to develop our sense
of self when we're young
but it occurs to me that the same
survival skills that we learn as young
kids to help us survive are some of the
same skills that we need to unlearn as
adults to help us live
we can't keep
repeating those same things that were
appropriate for a baby but we're adults
now and we have to mature out of that if
we really want to live
and that's where
the message of jesus i feel like is so
hopeful i mean
almost every song that i've ever written
talks about some sort of dying and i
just love them all i just i love them i
think it's just the most beautiful thing
but it's because i know the power inside
of it sets me free
and i need someone to help me die to
myself
because the truth is
none of us were meant to be an end in
ourselves
and when we adopt those patterns and the
self-obsession actually in truth it will
kill us
it will kill us
because we weren't made to live that way
no human being was
i there's a verse okay eileen i'm sorry
y'all we all love you eileen
i'm so sorry um
which one is it eileen that says
because i got a little ahead of myself
perhaps
um i need
is it philippians 2 5. let's see
where it talks about
you know i started to print this message
out it was over seven pages front and
back
i said forget it we're just gonna trust
the spirit
let's just go with philippians 2 5 for
now let's do it it's going to apply it's
going to work
that wasn't the one i was thinking of
but it's going
it's going to be good okay are you ready
philippians 2 5
your attitude should be the same as that
of christ jesus
who being in very nature god
did not consider equality with god
something to be grasped but made himself
nothing taking the very nature of a
servant being made in human likeness and
being found in appearance as a man he
humbled himself and became obedient to
death
even death on a cross
in the bible it says that
jesus came to show us the way to the
father
and the maggie version of that is jesus
came to reconnect us with the love of
god and all that is holy
and i think
all of us are on that quest in life
right i mean i feel like even
non-believers are on that quest we're
all trying to figure out how to get back
to what is holy how do i reconnect with
the love of god
and um
if jesus came to show us the way to the
father
then when we look at his life we can see
oh that's how we get there so when we
ask ourselves like
how do i get back my sense of peace
how do i get back to that sense of love
i think the example that christ left us
is being in very nature with god he did
not consider equality with god something
to be grasped and he's teaching us how
to let go
and i think the human
tendency
is instead to grasp
right like that's that is our tendency
is to hold on to things so tightly
and
for me i think there's two different
um
at least tonight the language i want to
use is there's two different postures
that we can take in the world
we can take the posture of survival
which is just grasping on to anything
that gives us identity grasping onto
anything that gives us purpose and value
or we can take
the way of surrender which is what i see
jesus doing on the cross
where instead of
grasping onto anything that gives us
purpose and value instead of holding
tightly to those things we let go of
them and we let god hold tightly to us
and
when
when i was thinking about like maggie
what are you saying when you're talking
about death what does that mean to die
to yourself
the definition i was using was dying to
anything
that would define me apart from the love
of christ
letting go of anything that says who i
am or how much value i have apart from
the love of christ and when jesus died
on the cross the reason he could choose
surrender is because he knew the most
valuable thing the most true thing about
him couldn't be killed
the most true thing about him was he was
the beloved of christ this is my son in
whom i am well pleased and you can nail
me to the cross and it's not going to
change that
and so as human beings we can lose
everything and it's not going to change
that we're the beloved of god
we're the child of god and nothing can
take that away and the the the life of
um
a believer i feel like is practicing
that truth
over and over and over again because
here's the thing whether we're choosing
death
in in a spiritual way
or whether it happens to us death keeps
coming
it keeps coming in all of its different
forms
it could be like the loss of a dream or
the loss of a job or the loss of a
marriage or the loss of people's good
opinion of you
and these things kill us
but
if we can enter in to death and
resurrection in those moments
and tell ourselves like
what if okay this is probably this is
something i probably shouldn't say but
just to put flesh on this
oh gosh it's 5 50. okay this is
when brett and i started the table
that was an extremely vulnerable process
and
because it was so vulnerable it was very
easy
to feel this need for it to thrive
this need
you know like it needs to be something
so that we don't look stupid in the end
you know what i mean
like
please stable
thrive
and i told bret one day on a walk we
were talking about like just confessing
out loud our fears which honestly i just
encourage all of us if you want to
practice death and resurrection just
start saying your fears out loud
start confessing them out loud to the
people closest to you and to god just
say them sometimes i mean i'm just
getting ready in the morning and i've
realized i'm in that anxious space and
i'm just i'm spinning with anxiety and i
literally have learned to just stop and
say maggie say exactly what you're
afraid of right now just say it because
it loses its power suddenly and i most
of the time look at it and just laugh
and i'm like oh my gosh maggie just stop
okay what are you
but when we started the table
i mean it was you know what i mean like
it just felt like this pressure to like
make sure you did the right thing so i
hope this thing really works because
otherwise it's going to be obvious that
you did the wrong thing to everyone
and
we were on this walk-in brett and i were
just confessing our fears
um i mean and we were laughing because
it was just stupid the things that we
would say
but
i told brett i said you know what my
favorite thing to do is right now and he
was like
okay what and i was like
i just like to imagine that it doesn't
work and he was like what and i was like
that the table dies what if the table
dies and i mean he was i really kind of
had to apologize i kind of hurt his
feelings but he was just like
what are you saying what do you say and
i was just like no i just mean i want to
face the worst case scenario
so that i can remember the truth
because you know what if the table dies
i still love you
and you still love me
and we're going to be fine
if the table dies i'm going to keep on
doing the same thing i've been doing
i'm going to live out the gospel in
whatever form people will allow me to do
that
i'm just going to keep on doing it when
we allow ourselves to surrender to death
and resurrection there is this power
because
whatever it is that we're afraid of
it
it actually gets to be seen up
juxtaposed against the what is actually
true you know and if you face the worst
case scenario
even then
you're left with
one thing that will never go away
you are the beloved of god
that is the story of jesus you can't
kill it
it doesn't go away
so welcome it invite it surrender to it
open up
let it take its way in you in day after
day moment after moment every time i'm
in a conflict with a friend i tell
myself death and resurrection maggie
death and resurrection do not let your
ego get in the way
you know like every this is just
it applies to every situation that we're
in just allow it allow it to die in
front of you and let god resurrect it
into something that's real something
that can't be killed
so
because i have gone over time
um i'm gonna stop there
i am gonna ask will if he will come and
read our celtic invitation to the table
while he does that i did have a song
that i wrote
around this topic that it felt
like too
specific to what we're talking about
tonight to not share it
so
while you guys are taking communion i'm
just going to be singing that in the
background
and then the worship team will come up
and close us in a song but will if you
don't mind coming and giving the
invitation to the table that would be
awesome
[Applause]
this is the table
not of the church but of the lord
it is made ready for those who love him
and for those who want to love him
you who have much faith and you who have
little
you who have been here often and you who
have
not been here long
you have tried to follow
and
you who have failed
come because it is the lord who invites
you it is his will
that those who want him should meet him
here
come to the table
[Music]
you put a seat into
the ground
you let it die and watch
[Music]
but what is
after the rains have fallen down
[Music]
there was a man who walked the earth
said he would give a second birth
[Music]
he always preached the way
to life
[Music]
and then he spread his arms
and i'm trying
to
learn how to die
and i'm wanting
[Music]
and i'm hoping
that this death
[Music]
of myself i pay
the price
[Music]
so need the soil i find myself
within the breaking of this shell
and the
identities i've known
oh giving way for life to cry
[Music]
and i'm hoping
that this death gives way to life
as i'm giving off
i pay
the price
to live
[Music]
and there's something in this
mystery
it keeps
strategies
[Music]
and i'm trying
to learn
[Music]
to stop living to
survive
i'm believing
that your death gave way to life
cause
even after love was crucified
[Music]
it lives
thanks maggie
great job great job
you guys want to stand with us we're
going to close
um with a hymn
that you may be familiar with
that just kind of talks about
the cross of jesus and what it means for
us and how we also have the opportunity
to lay our lives down
so if you guys want to sing with us as
we close out and then you'll be
dismissed
[Music]
when
i surveyed
on
which the prince
the glory
[Music]
and
is
[Music]
combos
oh wonderful
cross
beats me come and die
and find
the out
[Music]
cross
oh the
wonderful cross
all who gather here by grace draw
and bless your name
[Music]
love
so amazing
so
divine
demons my soul
my life
[Music]
it's me come and
oh
[Music]
love so amazing
so
david
demands my soul
my
[Music]
thank you so much for being with us
tonight
i hope most of all you feel the very
tangible real love of jesus
that is the center that we stand on here
and i promise you no matter what you're
going through that center holds
i can say that personally
as someone who almost lost their
marriage
who's had some really tough moments with
one of my kids
and a lot of other things that center
will hold
and
the hardest thing is to open your hands
and let go
and dare to hope
so my prayer for you tonight before i go
into the benediction
is a prayer of hope
for you a prayer of hope sometimes
that's the miracle
is showing up
believing that center will hold
and hoping
um
if you're new i'm so glad you were here
tonight what a great night to be here um
if you would before you leave right out
the the door here to your right there
are small cards with a pen if you could
write your name and contact information
put it in the box we'd love a chance to
connect with you this week
don't forget about samarama if you would
like to volunteer the sign up sheet is
on the table before you leave this room
and then there's also the link online if
you look at our facebook page or
instagram page you can get that link to
sign your kiddos up we would love to
have them and remember to invite others
to that as well
you can also use that box in the back
for giving or you can give online at
thetabletx.org
one of the reasons why gary and i give
to the table
is one of my favorite quotes about money
is every time you spend money you're
casting a vote for the kind of world you
want
and i want a world that's inclusive
thoughtful vulnerable eclectic
full of love and so if you would like to
give
you can do that in the box or you can do
that online
lastly
i would love to send you out with a
benediction you're already standing
if you are so inclined you can open your
hands in a posture of receiving these
words i believe they are true true true
for each and every one of you
and especially those of you that are
standing there thinking oh not me not me
especially for you so i hope you really
receive these and soak these words in
you are a child of god
you
are a child
of god
this is true on your best day
and it's especially true on your worst
day
so as you go into the week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go
with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted just
as you are
and go
filled with god's holy spirit
and the desire to extend these same
gifts of unconditional love and grace
to everyone you come in contact with
this week
be blessed have a good night we hope to
see you back here next sunday
good night
[Music]